okay Bernie Sanders is now playing the
last card that the progressive movement
has been waiting for in the 2020
Democratic primary and it is the Warren
card Bernie Sanders is now asking
Elizabeth Warren and her supporters to
support him in the upcoming primaries
tomorrow night next Tuesday night that
will probably basically be it for the
primary but there are also primaries
happening after that point and Bernie
needs her support and more importantly
her supporters are what he needs or
otherwise he is likely going to be done
after tomorrow night and that that is
just looking at the polls now he could
reverse this right we've looked at the
numbers the mathematical importance of
tomorrow night is now clear to everybody
yesterday Bernie Sanders publicly made a
pitch to Warren and to her supporters he
did a bunch of talk shows the Sunday
political talk shows and he said
essentially I'm progressive a lot of
Elizabeth Warren's policies are
progressive although they're a little
different from mine but there is some
consensus there I am the natural fit for
Warren's supporters is what Bernie said
yesterday on CNN
Bernie saying quote we would love to
have senator Warren's support we would
love to have the millions of people who
supported senator Warren senator Warren
talked about a wealth tax something I
think is enormous ly important we also
have a wealth tax nuanced different from
hers but the same principle at a time of
massive income and wealth inequality
we've reached out we're looking and
asking for the support of Senator Warren
supporters and hope they come on board
then on NBC's Meet the Press Bernie was
asked about the so-called nastiness of
some of his supporters that Elizabeth
Warren talked about in interviews after
she dropped out of the race and Bernie
sang on NBC's Meet the Press quote I am
concerned about the kind of ugliness
that exists on the internet and the
Twitter world in general it is very ugly
and I will not deny for a second that we
have some people who claim to be
supporters although I have a hard time
understanding why they think they can
support me and make vicious personal
attacks against people that's not what
our
campaign is about so Bernie sort of
suggesting that they claim to be his
supporters but maybe they're really not
but that he's against the nastiness no
matter what again another instance of
extending an olive branch to Warren
supporters and the reality is the Bernie
campaign realizes what's going on not
only does he need Warren support and her
supporters if he wants a shot at this
there are two issues even if he gets it
number one is that it's not at all clear
that a lot of Warren's supporters are
definitely going to go easily to Bernie
Sanders my estimate is that the most
optimistic scenario is that even with an
endorsement from Elizabeth Warren Bernie
doesn't get more than two-thirds at the
absolute most generous calculation not
does not get more than two-thirds of
Warren supporters a third are absolutely
going to Joe Biden even with an
endorsement from Elizabeth Warren and
then as far as the endorsement itself it
is not clear to me that Warren's
preference is for Bernie Sanders to win
especially now that he is down so far in
national polls in the upcoming state
polls he's not doing well I don't know
what Elizabeth Warren has to gain from
endorsing Bernie at this point in time
most recently before dropping out I also
don't know that Warren has the total
support to make this reasonable and to
go out on a limb from her perspective
even if Warren recognizes that her
policies and Bernie's are the closest to
when you look at she had 12 or 13
percent support before dropping out
Biden's currently up 15 or more
nationally so even if Bernie got 100
percent of Warren support he would still
be behind and again not 100% of Warren
support is going to go to Bernie Sanders
so Bernie's doing the right thing this
is the last card left to play he he's
going all-in essentially to use a poker
analogy because he may not get to see
too many more hands if he doesn't make
something happen tomorrow night he's
spending time in Michigan the
opportunists over at Fox News offered
Bernie a Town Hall tonight in Michigan
and Bernie is right to do it regardless
of fox news's motives they want to do it
for the money for the ratings because
the last one did well
Bernie's doing everything he
and so his eggs are in the Michigan
basket the latest Michigan polls are
Biden plus 24 and Biden plus 21 but that
is Bernie's shot 125 delegates in
Michigan I believe if Biden wins
Michigan it is over
I believe if Bernie can win Michigan and
by some margin he justifies at least a
hypothetical mathematical path to March
17th it's down to tomorrow night it is
all about a but a must-win for Bernie
Sanders we will have live coverage
tonight of the Fox News Town Hall and we
will have live coverage tomorrow night
as the results come in all of it live on
our youtube twitch and Facebook channels
in the meantime let me know your
prediction for tomorrow night I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me there let
me know what you think I want to tell
you about one of our sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk
and now breakfast has gotten much more
boring magic spoon is a new cereal
company that has discovered how to
recreate your favorite childhood cereals
with zero sugar 12 grams of protein and
just 3 grams of net carbs per serving
they offer four flavors based on the
classics cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry plus the variety pack which
lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its kedo
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon comm slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee
if you don't like it for any reason
you'll get a refund no questions asked
that's magic spoon comm slash Pakman
promo code Pakman for shipping